HAVE FURTHER UPDATES THROUGHOUT
THE NIGHT.
WE'LL BRING THOSE TO YOU HERE ON
FOX NEWS.
BRET?
>> Bret: CLAUDIA COWAN LIVE ON
SCENE.
THANK YOU.
BACK TO OTHER NEWS.
A LAWYER WITH TIES TO FORM A
CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN PAUL MANAFORT
IS HEADED FOR PRISON.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS LIVE
TONIGHT WITH A LANDMARK DECISION
IN THE RUSSIAN SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THIS MORNING, 33-YEAR-OLD
ENTERED FEDERAL COURT WHERE HE
WAS SENTENCED TO LYING TO
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         I
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         V
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         S
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         I
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         A
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         O
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         S
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS         .
A MAXIMUM -- FIVE YEARS IN
PRISON.
HE GOT 30 DAYS IN PRISON,
$20,000 FINE AND TWO MONTHS OF
SUPERVISED RELEASE.
THE DUTCH LAWYER WORKED WITH
RICK GATES, FORMER BUSINESS
PARTNER OF PAUL MANAFORT.
GATES IS NOW COOPERATING WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATORS.
MR. VAN DER ZWAAN ALSO WORKED
WITH PAUL MANAFORT, WHO IS
BRIEFLY THE CHAIRMAN AND NOW
FACES MONEY LAUNDERING AND TAX
FRAUD CHARGES.
BASED ON COURT FILINGS, SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATORS ARE
EXPLORING CONTACTS BETWEEN THE
THREE MEN AND IT EXPECTED
OPERATIVE.
A NEWLY PUBLIC MEMO EXPLAINS
THAT AUTHORITIES ALLOWED THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE
EVENTS PRIOR TO THE 2016
CAMPAIGN.
THE VOCAL PAGE MEMO WAS DRAFTED
BY ROD ROSENSTEIN IN AUGUST,
2017, WITH ENTIRE SENTENCE
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HE
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HG
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HV
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HE
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HM
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HL
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HR
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HP
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HW
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HR
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HT
BLANKED OUT WITH SHOWING THAT HO
INVESTIGATE MORE OF COLLUSION.
HE COULD HAVE COMMITTED CRIME OR
CRIMES ARISING FROM THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
IN A SEPARATE DEVELOPMENT, THE
WIFE OF FIRED FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW McCABE WENT ON THE
RECORD CALLING LASTER A
NIGHTMARE FOR HER FAMILY.
WRITING IN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
AFTER JILL McCABE, WHO RAN
UNSUCCESSFULLY FOR A VIRGINIA
STATE SENATE SEAT IN 2015, SAID
HER HUSBAND DID NOT CAMPAIGN FOR
HER DESPITE THEIR WIDELY
CIRCULATED PHOTO.
SHE SAYS IT WAS MEANT FOR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
DR. McCABE ALSO SAYS THE FBI
ETHICS PANEL CONCLUDED THERE WAS
NO CONFLICT FOR HER HUSBAND WHEN
SHE RECEIVED MORE THAN $600,000
FROM DEMOCRATS INCLUDING A
LONGTIME CLINTON ALLY, BECAUSE
HER HUSBAND'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
CLINTON EMAIL CASE CAME AFTER
THE CONTRIBUTIONS WERE MADE IN
THE RACE WAS OVER.
"I HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
PRESIDENT AND SO MANY OTHERS CAN
SHARE SUCH INSTRUCTIVE LIES
ABOUT ME.
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
THE WHOLE STORY THAT EVERYTHING
IS BASED ON IS JUST FALSE
AND UTTERLY ABSURD."